阿部3パターン
あったアジアは w だ
[音楽]
ん
こんにちははじめちゃうんです僕の前進をかたどった等身大肇社長クレイがここにある
んですけども
簡単に言うと僕の完全なるコピーなんですかね米シーンすべてのパーツ完璧に僕の再生
下げて
後ほぼ僕がクローンといっても価格がないんですよねこんな可愛らしいや風をしそうな
んですけども私一つ気になる事がありまして
このここに
輪郭とか本目とか鼻とか口とか全てのパーツが僕と一緒だったらちょっとしたら
iphone のフェイス id
顔認証ぐ人でを言って実家からと思いますねこれできたらヤバイっすよ風味で犯罪が
できますから音ズレに誰からコミュに入ってこの済みのカウンターに切り取ればいいと
僕のスマホ使いもないですから
今まで人類で組で sid
突破した人今んかいないんですよ今日はそれちょっとできる方は行ってみたいと思い
ます実際できたらまずにあげるぞ
頑張れよよごめんなさいねちょっと肌白いのは
方からこの日撮る時に何かくっついてると撮れないんで取るようにちょっといろいろね
つけさせていただいてこうだっちゃいました
これ凄いって事はそれ自分途中できるということを失礼します
ドキドキしちゃう俺と今まで通じてきた人はどんな感覚で僕と2していたのでしょうか
自分で自分にチューしてみようと思います
[音楽]
良い唇 i- pod 来て6粒入れ仲いいですねー
たいという気で食べ僕のかを知ってる人ならわかると思うんですけど結構ガチで見てる
んですよ
唇の活動でてるし花ダシを取ってるしてべとかもベッツビューそっくりなんで僕が坊主
になると大体こんな感じだと思います
持ち上げアイドル早速やってみようと思います顔のパターンにてるんで
小さいね方にをもとに合ってるかは
ちょっと分かんないんだけどまず僕ですねそれこのロックが下手ですか
実行すると
はい人気てますてっていう感じでいけます
ますそれで僕の彼は僕の頭までさすがに行きますけど果たしてこの後でどうなるの
でしょうか
ではやってみます
築城あれをいただきますえっ
うん
俺でしょ俺だよねー俺俺俺
俺えっ i まあ俺だぞ
なんでだよ
しっかりしてるよおいはいえー
やはりなぜダメなのかな俺だと何が違うめっちゃ似てると思うのだレっぽいですね
このに目とか全部見てるのに髪の毛から感覚して行ってみよう
だめだめっちゃに年度に売れ俺あーもう立って何基準で済んだよね
人間っぽさを求めてるんだったらなんか顔の動きとが大事なんかな
あっえっ
it it it 一体一体たイッターって肺ドックされている
縦振り縦振りかこれ長谷部リーダーがスティぶりで今へ今完全に解除して
の表情筋の何かが強いとかもっ今完全に行きましたら一回もまずで
今奇跡だったら入って上げた分今ではほぼ奇跡でしたね
なんか奇跡的に ek できたんですけどちょっと怪しいだっ
人じゃねえ組ですおかしいですねこんなに継承できる人そういないと思うんで
検証結果組の顔だと制裁 d はほぼ
いけないということが分かりました移動で等身大の国の組がいるんで
スノーとがやってみましょう1階ではなんか顔認証引っかかったんでちょっとスノーと
かでも反応すると思ってねアーサーこぼすのをやってみましょう
ドアねっっ相撲取りかそうか甘え組七海4つのモデルなぁ
ぷれジョブ
ややをばやる組た4組じゃない僕はもう1人
そしてを入れているそう小山崎本文ですねはい
ん
ミイラ4安打もミラーあ
可愛いあなた可愛いかわいい the これちょっとやってみましょうか
出来上がりちゃーん
黙れあ流れ
たまに反応してくれないかなを超えでしょうか
はいはーい
そう僕バルに取れるぐらいですねさあ来ましたこれができたですね
組に日々を生やしてみましょう
うん
ん
ちゃんと生ラーメンだ全然ハウスでたまーに話せるのなんかいっ
角度が誰なのかなそういうふうに思いちょっとうまくいかないですねこれ
はいというわけですね組で首脳は球に反応するくらいですからやっぱりほどいい顔系
なければ反応しないかもしれない音止めた
すべきでこれ弾み設備なんですけど絶対食べる予定なんですけどもうちょっと術食べる
のもったいないんでちょっといろいろ遊びを実験してみようかなと思います保存
をしっかりさせていただいております動画でちょっとまだ出るか分からんですけどもう
ちょっと遊びつつを黒でやつ見たいことがあったらぜひコメント欄に書いてみて
ください
もうこんな機会ないですからねいうわけでまた寒いところでも撮りますよねっ
me
car
うううう
me
car
あっはぁ